valérian s'est pas seulement parce que
ça héros de sf qui les révolutionnaires
en france c'est aussi parce qu'il est en
couple et et valérian émana voilà y'a
laureline et ça c'était unique non
seulement parce qu'il y avait une
héroïne féminine mais en plus parce que
c'est la coupe oui mais il y avait
surtout qu'il n'y avait quasiment pas de
femmes dans la bande dessinée pour petit
garçon comme dit christain la bande
dessinée cet effet par des vieux petit
garçon pour des jeunes petit garçon et
et tout ça cette édition de cowboy de
flics de militaires de ce qu'on veut
alors que nous on avait envie de parler
du monde et des mondes possibles mais
aussi surtout
des rapports de gens d un début d
écologie qui se relie ferait bien le
truc et les poubelles de l'espace est
déjà là dans le dessin et et surtout un
rapport très égalitaire c'est à dire que
leur livre n'est pas du tout une potiche
elle est très jolie elle est très sexy
mais c'est surtout légal de valérian
absolument mais ça c'est une volonté du
scénariste pierre klein absolument
d'abord avec le fait que je crois que
notre alliance
elle dit ça mais elle se tient comme ça
en me disant ça c'était moi
et ça je pense qu'on a bien ici on a
bien réussi à dents comme ce personnage
plus vivant et puisqu'on nous avons
maintenant 2000 3000 petit laureline en
france oui ah oui elle s'appelle
lauréline des filles et qui a observé
des sous titres des grandes ombres
proférées maintenant j'ai des grandes
laureline de 20 ans qu'à 10 et mon
compagnon s'appelle valait rien
[Musique]